Україна минулоріч посіла 11 місце
за обсягом експорту зброї в світі,
при цьому її основний імпортер - Росія.
Такі дані оприлюднив Стокгольмський інститут проблем миру.
Разом з тим, ще у 2014 році
РНБО видало рішення, згідно з яким наказало
"вжити заходів щодо припинення експорту до Росії
товарів військового призначення".
ДВ перевірила
Офіційно Україна не постачає зброю до країни-агресора.
"Укроборонпром" заявив, що "контролює,
щоб жодна гайка не потрапила до ворога".
Відсутність офіційного експорту озброєнь підтвердили
і в Державній службі експортного контролю України.
За їхніми даними, від ухвалення відповідного рішення РНБО
"українським підприємствам не було надано жодного дозволу
на експорт зазначених товарів російським користувачам".
З огляду на це виникає питання:
то який експорт має на увазі Стокгольмський інститут проблем миру.
На запит Deutsche Welle, у SIPRI пояснили, що йдеться
про поставки двигунів для Як-130 та для фрегатів
а також Ан-140 та Ан-178.
Що стосується двигунів для Як-130 та фрегатів,
замовлення на них датуються 2014 роком
або початком 2015, зазначають у SIPRI.
А за методологією інституту,
роком постачання вважається рік, коли готовий продукт
передали збройним силам Росії.
Так, один фрегат спустили на воду в 2016,
і ще два в 2017 році.
Інші три проекти заморозили через відсутність українських двигунів.
Два недобудовані кораблі купила Індія,
яка дозамовила українські двигуни, щоб добудувати судна.
Утім, таке постачання українських двигунів російським кораблям,
за методологією SIPRI, не вважається експортом України в Росію.
Україна офіційно припинила експорт зброї в Росії.
Розбіжності зі звітом SIPRI викликані тим,
що міжнародні експерти ширше тлумачать поняття експорту зброї.
Вони відносять сюди і ліцензії
на будівництво АНів на Воронезькому авіаційному заводі,
і поставлені раніше
але взяті на озброєння лише в 2017 році двигуни для російських фрегатів.
Єдиний шлях, яким українська зброя може потрапити до країни-агресора -
контрабанда або офшори.
Випадки контрабанди визнали у Державній службі експортного контролю
та заявили: щодо підозрюваних відкриті кримінальні провадження.
Про офшорні схеми продажу зброї Росії говорять військові експерти,
проте жодного слідства щодо цього не ведеться.